yo nevah canta la esperanza que yo tuve
my doloroso contar ESO porque es uno y
on Oct record our day I'll tell you
about my experience it's very painful to
talk about this because you'd rather
forget about the problems you've had
what happened to me is not the first
case there are thousands and thousands
of cases in Guatemala that have occurred
and that are happening now and sometimes
you ask yourself who is going to fix the
situation in Guatemala it is really
difficult yo primero pues mijo y mira
que darle una tienda yessum first my
wife told me I want to help you run a
store and then at one point the store
was robbed they jumped over the counter
because back then they didn't have the
bars that they use today for security my
wife and a family member were there they
pointed a gun at them and said they
wanted the money from the sales and they
gave it to them afterwards I got a loan
from the company to install the security
bars things were going more or less well
at the store we were getting by and then
other people showed up and demanded
money from my store they wanted 50 gets
Alice per week I said I have to pay it
maybe you don't think now why do you pay
it instead of going to the police you do
it because you're afraid you should
report it but the police don't do
anything
the end of
I remember when I have the store there
was a law that you couldn't sell liquor
after 8pm so I closed up and told these
men at 8pm you can't sell anything
because the police will come and I don't
want trouble but they stayed there I
turned off the lights they stayed
talking I closed everything and the
police came and knocked on the door and
he asked me are you selling liquor here
I said I sold it to them but i'm not
selling anymore he said you'll have to
come with me there were about seven
policemen I said but why if I'm not
doing anything wrong give me your ID
card if he told me I thought if I refuse
they'll be problems I gave him my ID
look he said you'll have to come with me
because you were breaking the law no I
wasn't doing anything wrong he said ok
let's do something to settle this give
me six hundred kit solace and we'll
leave it at that I had 500 get solace
not from the store I had to give it to
him out of my pocket to avoid problems
I'm ember one day when my daughter told
me dad I was robbed she was crying I
told her I already told you not to leave
work so late because it's dangerous
where we live no she said it happened
here she told me they put a gun to her
head and told her she had to give them
50 get solace per week so I decided to
close the store because I had no choice
my wife was upset and started to cry oh
my store she said to me going to temple
later they demanded a tax for the house
and when they threatened me they said
we're from organized crime we're going
to protect you we want 10,000 in one or
two hours we want the money
half an hour later they called again
asking if we had the money I told them
we didn't and they told me that the man
who's going to pick up the money is so
and so he has a mustache this is the
phone number and they gave me all the
instructions about how to hand over the
money if I'm being extorted I'm not
going to risk talking to the police I
remember that man who called told me we
know you're going to go to the police
and report it they'll protect you for
three months and then in three months
will show up and something is going to
happen to you so you're not going to
wait around for something to happen to
you it's better to avoid problems and so
we had to get out of our house and now
instead of having our own property we're
renting north on what a key London Dora
my wife used to be really fat and then
she got really skinny when she died she
was worse she had cancer but she also
died of sadness I've talked about this
with my daughters it was very hard for
me because we were together for 41 years
look at the drug trafficking who's in
charge of the gangs the drug traffickers
call the shots with the gangs that's
what I think is happening it is very
difficult to talk about these things but
someone has to hear it someone has to do
something for Guatemala the government
doesn't do anything they don't do
anything
Oh